the trial begins today of two men
suspected of murdering the prominent
dutch journalist peter r devries he was
shot at close range in amsterdam last
year and died nine days later
authorities believe the killing was
connected to an organized crime group
that he'd been investigating
a beloved journalist in the netherlands
peter devries spent his life in korea
fighting to uncover the truth behind
murders and crime stories many of which
law enforcement had given up on i stand
for my principles i think
i'm just doing my work that work though
set him against many of his country's
most criminal and most corrupt and on
july the 6th 2021 while leaving a tv
studio in central amsterdam he was shot
in the head from close range
[Music]
two men were arrested shortly after and
now stand trial for his murder
it was nine days after he was shot that
at the age of 64 peter de vries died in
hospital his murder rocked the nation
and people are looking to this trial to
deliver justice i truly hope from the
bottom of my heart that this this person
who did this
will be justified and
i i truly hope so but
it's just really unfortunate that these
things keep happening the assassination
is widely considered to be ordered by
the macro mafia criminal gang who had
already killed the brother and the
attorney of a key witness in the case
against them peter devries had been
supporting that witness
a report from dw correspondent jack
parrack in amsterdam who has been
following the trial welcome jack
tell us what happened in court today
well we've seen the two men accused in
this trial attend the court delano g a
22 year old dutch national arrived
wearing a black turtleneck he has a sort
of long beard short hair a sullen
disposition in the court today and he
has refused to answer any questions
invoking his right to remain silent
throughout this trial as we he had done
in the charges here hearing just a few
weeks ago now the other man camille e
he is accused of being the getaway
driver where delano is accused of being
the man that pulled the trigger he's a
polish national 35 years old he's
arrived in a white shirt he has tattoos
coming up onto his neck a very stocky
gentleman with a bold head and glasses
and he has been answering questions
his defense is that he was simply
employed as a driver to drive somebody
from rotterdam to amsterdam and that he
had no idea that a murder was going to
take place the prosecution in this case
though say that he was fully aware and
they have used cctv evidence to show
they suggest that he was on the street
where peter devries was killed just a
matter of days before the attack
actually happened and that he was part
of the planning of the attack uh camil e
has been saying in court that that the
person in this cctv isn't him but there
are a number of dna evidences linking
him to the murder weapon the two men
were arrested just outside
amsterdam just after the shooting
happened and the prosecution seemed to
feel that they should be able to get
this case wrapped up and perhaps you
could explain to us why this case is
being watched so very closely there
well firstly phil is because of the fame
of peter r devries he is one of the most
beloved one of the most famous
journalists he was on tv here in the
netherlands very very frequently but
secondly because of what has happened
and who he was supporting there's a case
against ridawan targhi who's the leader
of the macro mafia a major major
criminal gang here in the netherlands
and
one of the key witnesses in that case is
a man named nabil b this case has been
going on for a few years now but now
bills b's brother was already murdered
his lawyer was murdered and peter
devries was known to be supporting him
through that case against the macro
mafia so the assumption is is that the
hit was conducted uh or at least ordered
by the mafia bosses and the telegraph
which is a dutch newspaper
says that
delano g the man who is accused of
pulling the trigger is actually the
nephew of ridwan targhi that mafia boss
so it's all connected and it's linked to
this suggestion of not only an attack on
freedom of the press because of peter
devries but also an attack on the
justice system because of that lawyer
that was killed and that's why it's
raised
that's why this this trial is so high
profile and people in here in the
netherlands are watching intensively
because they want to see justice served
thank you so much for that jack jack
parak in amsterdam